nos piden dividir 3x al cubo más 4x
cuadrada menos 2 x 1 entre x más 4
podríamos utilizar la división larga que
ya hemos visto en varios vídeos pero
ahorita quiero mostrarte una nueva
técnica que se conoce como división
sintética división
y visión sintética
estética y ahorita que la hagamos
ahorita que hagamos los pasos va a
aparecer así como como que es magia
después en otros vídeos vamos a ver por
qué funciona o sea porque da el mismo
resultado que utilizar la división larga
así la división tradicional va también
personalmente no me gusta mucho la
división sintética porque es muy
algorítmica es muy como seguir ciertos
pasos pero bueno claro que tiene sus
ventajas es más rápido y hacer la
división sintética que la división larga
tradicional y necesitas menos espacio en
el papel sin embargo hay dos cosas
importantes para cuando usamos la
división sintética y son las siguientes
tenemos que verificar que en el
denominador máximo haya términos de
grado uno va entonces aquí tenemos esta
equis y no hay potencias cúbicas ni
cuadradas ni nada más alto tiene que ser
x a la 1 y ya y otra cosa es que el
coeficiente de esa x tiene que ser 1
entonces aquí tenemos un uno implícito
no se vale que sea dos ni tres ni nada
más tiene que ser un uno hay otras
formas de ajustar la división sintética
para que funcione en otros casos raros
pero ahorita vamos a pedir esas dos
cosas exponente 1 y coeficiente 1 vale
bueno vamos a hacer los pasos el paso
número 1 es colocar los coeficientes los
coeficientes del polinomio de arriba
aquí a la derecha en algún lugar hacia
así hacia la derecha entonces este 3 lo
pongo por aquí y luego este 4 también lo
tengo que lo tengo que poner por allí 4
luego pongo el el menos 2 menos dos y
finalmente pongo el menos uno menos uno
muy bien ahora dependiendo de quién te
cuente este método va a ser las cosas un
poquito diferentes pero básicamente lo
mismo ahora lo que yo haría es poner
esta casita boca abajo esta casita que
va así y observa que estoy dejando un
renglón para tener espacio para ciertas
operaciones que ahorita quiero hacer
y aquí afuera tenemos que poner otro
número que tiene que ver con este
término constante del denominador nada
más que ver si estoy aquí es un +4 le
cambiamos el signo a menos 4 menos 4 y
eso lo vamos a poner aquí afuerita menos
4 si fuera negativo lo cambiamos a
positivo hay que poner el negativo del
término constante de el denominador vale
muy bien entonces ahora sí vamos a
realizar las operaciones otra vez esto
va a parecer magia pero por el momento
sigue me la corriente y después vemos
por qué funciona entonces lo primero que
se hace es que este 3 baja directamente
a este espacio
entonces bajas y directamente vale luego
este 3 lo vamos a multiplicar por este
menos 43 por menos 4 es menos 12 y ese
menos 12 ese menos 12 va a ir aquí vale
entonces aquí va menos 12 ahora tenemos
que sumar estos dos términos 4 con menos
12 4 con menos 12 es menos 8
y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es el
-4 multiplicarlo por el menos 8 ya se
empieza a ver el patrón verdad menos 4 x
menos 8 pues menos por menos es más 4
por 8 es 32 y ahora sumamos sumamos
menos 2 con 32 que nos da igual a 30 nos
da igual a 30 va y ahora el 30 lo
multiplicamos por menos 4 misma idea
este va para acá arriba para acá arriba
este 30 por menos 4 es menos 120
no voy a poner así menos 120 y
finalmente hacemos esta suma menos 120
menos 1 es igual a menos 120 uno muy
bien entonces de aquí ya podemos leer la
respuesta fíjate está bien padre aquí
tenemos un 4 que nada más es un término
entonces separamos un término real
entonces este menos 121 lo separamos y a
partir de ahí lo que tenemos son los
coeficientes de la equis en exponente
creciente aquí tenemos el término
constante aquí el de grado 1 y aquí el
de grado 2
ahorita este menos 121 va a tener que
ver con el residuo pero déjame empezar
con estos
este 30 quiere decir que tenemos por
aquí un 30
así constante va más 30 luego este menos
8 es el término que le corresponde a x a
x a la 1 entonces aquí sería menos 8x a
la 1 bueno ya no le pongo el a la 1 vale
luego este 3 correspondería al término
cuadrática x al cuadrado entonces este 3
va aquí y es 3x al cuadrado y finalmente
este menos 121 es lo que sobra esto esté
menos 121 bases va a ser el residuo y
por lo tanto podemos poner esto como un
más bueno déjame ponerlo en menos para
que quede bonito menos 121 / / / x más 4
entre x
4 muy bien entonces esto de aquí esto de
aquí esta expresión ya sería la
respuesta de nuestra división vale está
aquí es la respuesta de nuestra división
y funciona también si tienes más
potencias y para polinomios más grandes
arriba la única restricción de ésta en
el polinomio de abajo bueno en los
siguientes vídeos voy a ver otro ejemplo
y después vamos a pensar por qué este
método de división sintética funciona